>>> NEW DETAILS TONIGHT IN THE
JANUARY 6th INVESTIGATION.
EARLIER, I HEARD FROM THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE HOUSE SELECT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING THE RIOT
BENNIE THOMPSON.
HE TELLS ME THAT PHONE CALLS
WITH THE WILLARD HOTEL WAR ROOM
WHERE A LOT OF TRUMP ALLIES AND
AIDES TO THE FORMER PRESIDENT
WERE GATHERED ARE A KEY PART OF
THE PROBE, AND THEY ARE LOOKING
INTO, QUOTE, ANYONE WHO WAS ON
THEM.
MEANING, THEY MAY BE LOOKING AT
POSSIBLE PHONE CALLS, INCLUDING
WITH THE FORMER PRESIDENT.
THIS COMES, AS THE BRUTAL NATURE
OF THAT RIOT WAS DISPLAYED, ONCE
AGAIN.
A THREE-HOUR VIDEO HAS BEEN
RELEASED SHOWING THE BATTLE
BETWEEN RIOTERS AND POLICE
DURING THE INSURRECTION.
SHOWING RIOTERS SPRAYING POLICE
WITH PEPPER SPRAY, HITTING THEM
WITH A BATON, AND EVEN STEALING
A SHIELD FROM OFFICERS.
OUR NEXT GUEST PREDICTED THE
INSURRECTION IN A SERIES OF
TWEETS, MORE THAN TWO WEEKS
BEFORE THE RIOT ON DECEMBER
21st, THIS IS WHAT HE WROTE.
QUOTE, ON JANUARY 6th, ARMED
TRUMPIST MILITIAS WILL BE
RALLYING IN D.C. AT TRUMP'S
ORDERS.
IT IS HIGHLY LIKELY THAT THEY
WILL TRY TO STORM THE CAPITOL
AFTER IT CERTIFIED JOE BIDEN'S
WIN.
I DON'T THINK THIS HAS SUNK IN
YET.
PERSPECTIVE NOW FROM THE AUTHOR
OF THAT TWEET, EXTREMISM AND
POLITICAL ANALYST AND FOUNDING
WRITER OF THE HAT TIP, A
ARIA CAVLER.
YOUR TWITTER THREAT OBVIOUSLY
PROVED TO BE TERRIBLY PRESCIENT.
HOW WAS IT YOU WERE ABLE TO SEE
WHAT THE AMERICAN PUBLIC, U.S.
MILITARY, LAW ENFORCEMENT
COMMUNITY WERE NOT ABLE TO SEE
COMING?
>> I THINK -- I THINK KEEPING A
VERY CLOSE EYE ON THOSE FORUMS
AND PUBLIC SPACES OPEN IN PUBLIC
WHERE TRUMP'S MOST HARDCORE
SUPPORTERS MET AND TALKED.
AND THE ONE THING YOU HAVE GOT
TO REMEMBER IS THAT FOR SEVERAL
MONTHS, THEY WERE ABSOLUTELY
CONVINCED THAT TRUMP WAS GOING
TO WIN THE ELECTION AND WIN BIG,
YOU KNOW, HE WAS GOING TO WIN
CALIFORNIA.
40, 45 STATES.
AND THEN, AFTER ELECTION DAY,
WHEN OBVIOUSLY HE LOST, TRUMP
CONTINUED TO SAY I -- I'VE WON.
UM, AND YOU WILL SEE SOON AND
THEY ALL BELIEVED HIM BUT THEY
DIDN'T JUST BELIEVE THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN, THEY BELIEVED TRUMP
HAD A PLAN TO WIN.
AND ANY DAY NOW, IT WAS GOING TO
BE PROVED.
AND JANUARY THE 6th WAS THE LAST
REAL DAY THAT YOU COULD KEEP
THAT FANTASY ALIVE.
AND SO, WHEN TRUMP HIMSELF
SUMMONED THEM TO D.C. ON JANUARY
THE 6th, THIS WAS REALLY ONLY
GOING TO GO ONE WAY.
THESE WERE PEOPLE WHO ARE COMING
TO D.C. EXPECTING TO WATCH TRUMP
WIN SOMEHOW.
WHETHER THAT WAS BY CONGRESS
SOMEHOW, NEVERTHELESS, DECIDING
TO MAKE HIM THE PRESIDENT AND
THROW OUT THE -- THE BIDEN
VOTES.
OR WHETHER IT WAS BY TRUMP USING
THE MILITARY OR PERHAPS THE
CROWD THEMSELVES AS THE MILITIA
TO BASICALLY STORM CONGRESS AND
INSTALL A DICTATORSHIP.
SO ONCE THEY WERE THERE AND THEY
WERE THERE BECAUSE HE CALLED
THEM THERE, I THINK IT WAS ONLY
GOING TO GO ONE WAY.
>> AND THESE THREAT STREAMS, YOU
WERE SEEING.
THEY WERE PUBLICLY -- PUBLICLY
VISIBLE AT THE TIME, CORRECT?
I UNDERSTAND YOU THOUGHT A
WARNING FROM YOU DIRECTLY TO THE
FBI WASN'T NECESSARY BUT YOU
WERE CONCERNED ENOUGH TO TWEET
ABOUT IT.
AND I WAS LOOKING AT SOME OF
THESE TWEETS EARLIER TODAY.
THEY'VE BEEN RETWEETED THOUSANDS
OF TIMES NOW.
SO OBVIOUSLY, THEY -- IT'S HAD
AN IMPACT.
>> YEAH.
LOOK.
I MEAN, IT NEVER OCCURRED TO
ME -- THE FBI OR ANYBODY BECAUSE
TO ME IT WOULD BE LIKE CALLING
UP THE INAUGURATION PARADE TO
TELL THEM THERE WAS GOING TO BE
RAIN.
YOU KNOW?
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT WAS SO
OBVIOUS THAT THE AUTHORITIES
WOULD AND SHOULD HAVE KNOWN
ABOUT.
IN FACT, I SPOKE TO OTHER PEOPLE
AFTER JANUARY THE 6th THAT SAID
THEY DID CALL THE FBI WITH WHAT
THEY SAW.
UM, SO EVEN IF I HAD, I DON'T
THINK IT WOULD HAVE MADE REALLY
ANY DIFFERENCE.
>> AND WE SHOWED SOME VIDEO IN
YOUR INTRODUCTION THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT RELEASED
THIS-PAST WEEK OF ONE OF THE
BATTLES BETWEEN RIOTERS AND
POLICE AT THE U.S. CAPITOL
BUILDING ON JANUARY 6th.
WAS THIS THE LEVEL OF VIOLENCE
THAT YOU EXPECTED TO SEE?
WE ARE LOOKING AT SOME OF THIS
NOW.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, THE TRUTH IS I -- I
EXPECTED IT TO BE WORSE.
UM, IN SOME SENSES, I THINK THE
U.S. GOT EXTREMELY LUCKY ON
JANUARY THE 6th.
THE SHOOTING NEVER REALLY
STARTED AND IF IT HAD, THINGS
MIGHT HAVE REALLY GONE TERRIBLY
WORSE.
IT'S ONLY, REMEMBER, THE FLUKE
OF A COUPLE OF SECONDS AND THE
GOOD GRACES OF EUGENE GOODMAN,
OFFICER GOODMAN.
THE -- THE MOB DIDN'T END UP
CAPTURING SENATORS.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS THAT
COULD HAVE GONE MUCH WORSE THAN
THEY DID ON JANUARY THE 6th.
AND THE LEVEL OF VIOLENCE WE SAW
IS HORRIFYING TO SEE AND THE
FACT THAT IT WENT ON FOR SO
LONG, ALSO.
BUT IT WAS ALSO A MIRACLE THAT
THE SHOOTING DIDN'T REALLY START
AND IT MIGHT HAVE BEEN A
BLOODBATH THAT DAY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, YOU CAN ONLY IMAGINE
WHAT WOULD HAVE HAPPENED IF THEY
HAD CAPTURED MIKE PENCE OR -- OR
NANCY PELOSI OR MITT ROMNEY IN
ALL THOSE HARROWING SCENES.
UM, AND ARIA, WE ARE COMING UP
ON THE ANNIVERSARY OF JANUARY
6th AS YOU KNOW AND THERE ARE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS AHEAD IN 2022.
WHAT SORTS OF THINGS ARE BEING
TALKED ABOUT ONLINE RIGHT NOW
THAT ARE A CAUSE FOR CONCERN IN
THE WEEKS AHEAD?
WHAT ARE YOU PICKING UP ON THAT
MAYBE, ONCE AGAIN, PEOPLE HERE
IN THE UNITED STATES MAY NOT BE,
YOU KNOW, PAYING ENOUGH
ATTENTION TO?
>> IF YOU GO NOW INTO THE KIND
OF MAGA ONLINE SPACES, AND THE
ADJACENT QANON SPACES.
NOT EXACTLY THE SAME PEOPLE,
THOUGH THERE IS SOME CROSSOVER.
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE
CONVERSATION THERE IS ABOUT THE
PANDEMIC.
IT'S ALL VACCINES AND MANDATES
AND MASKS.
AND PROBABLY, THE NUMBER ONE
FIGURE RIGHT NOW AMONGST THAT
GROUP ISN'T PRESIDENT BIDEN.
IT ISN'T VICE PRESIDENT, EITHER.
IT'S ANTHONY FAUCI.
YOU KNOW, THEY ARE ABSOLUTELY
OBSESSED WITH FAUCI.
UM, THE PANDEMIC IS A HOAX.
THIS IS ALL A FORM OF CONTROL.
AND, YOU KNOW, FRANKLY, WHAT
WE'VE SEEN EVEN BEFORE JANUARY
THE 6th IS A LOT OF THIS
RIGHT-WING VIOLENCE DIRECTED AT
PANDEMIC -- YOU KNOW, THE
SEIZING OF THE STATE CAPITOLS IN
2020.
THE GOVERNOR WHITMER PLOT AND,
YOU KNOW, IF IT WAS ME, THAT --
THAT IS WHERE I WOULD BE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE POTENTIAL
FOR FUTURE VIOLENCE.
>> ARIA, THANKS VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME.
WE APPRECI